[SPEAKER_00]: ¿De qué parte?
[SPEAKER_00]: De Medellín.
[SPEAKER_00]: De Medellín, sí señor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo nací en Bogotá, pero me crié en Medellín.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y me vine aquí persiguiendo a Sofía, al amor.
[SPEAKER_00]: No sé si la conoces, que es amiga de Andrea.
[SPEAKER_02]: No la conozco, pero algo me platicó Andy y es de valientes eso.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso es de valientes, estar de un país a otro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es difícil de por si en el país propio le batallamos ahora imagina en otro país ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: ajeno el grupo porque te felicito.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muchas gracias.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya no existen, ya no hay hombres de esos ¿eh?
[SPEAKER_02]: Te felicito para que te valoren.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mil gracias, eso espero.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso espero que así sea, que lo valoren.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si, si, si.
[SPEAKER_02]: Además este, como dicen los políticos, son dos países hermanos, Colombia y Chile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, bueno, en realidad nosotros vinimos de España, desde España, nos conocimos en España, pero bueno, ya nos vinimos para acá, pero como dices, son países hermanos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, yo conozco Bogotá, conozco Medellín, Cartagena, y lo conozco hace unos 25 años, eran de los mejores diseñadores en ropa interior.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ellos y los venezolanos.
[SPEAKER_00]: En Medellín había una muy grande, Leonisa se llamaba.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ellos se dedicaban a la vida de los mejores diseñadores y con el cambio de gobierno y todo eso se los robó unas compañías chinas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todo el talento, diseñadores y la ropa interior.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hace 24, 23 años que yo portaba ropa interior y se llevaban los chinitos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Una compañía de Miami entre los chinitos y unos de Miami se llevaron el talento.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bueno, muchachos muy educados, jóvenes así, talentosos.
[SPEAKER_02]: En Bogotá educados se levantan muy temprano, nosotros como nosotros.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hoy se levanta la gente muy temprano para el tráfico.
[SPEAKER_02]: Con lo que es Bogotá y Medellín nunca diseñaron la ciudad.
[SPEAKER_02]: A futuro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Corrígeme si estoy mal.
[SPEAKER_02]: En aquel entonces había tráfico.
[SPEAKER_02]: Estaban los 75, 66 años.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mediante hoy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hoy, Dios me lo juro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Se levanta nena
[SPEAKER_02]: Te pueden citar a las... nos vemos en la mañana, nosotros la mañana es las 10 y las 11.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, ellos la mañana es las 6, a la mañana es las 7 y ya están trabajando.
[SPEAKER_02]: El tráfico.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, así es.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oye, eso fue hace 25 años, imagínate, ya hoy en día es bastante más complicado.
[SPEAKER_00]: El tráfico en Medellín hace 25 años no era tan pesado, pero la ciudad ha crecido muchísimo, ha tenido una expansión muy grande y se ha congestionado mucho.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gente muy educada.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tú le preguntabas a una persona en la calle de 16, 17 años una dicción, una forma de hablar, educadísimos.
[SPEAKER_02]: No me preguntes por qué, pero muy educados.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y Medellín, por eso ahí está el talento de todas esas artistas que han salido a emigrar de Medellín.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todas las artistas nuevas, mucho talento, mucho talento.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y lo mejor es que te hablan hermoso.
[SPEAKER_02]: Enamoran.
[SPEAKER_02]: Enamoran todo.
[SPEAKER_00]: No sé qué está haciendo aquí con una mexicana.
[SPEAKER_00]: Las mexicanas también enamoran.
[SPEAKER_00]: Estoy vacilando.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero platícame.
[SPEAKER_00]: Primero agradecerte por el espacio que me abrieron ustedes tres.
[SPEAKER_00]: María, vos, Héctor y Andre.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me estaba contando que ustedes están buscando la forma de pronto de
[SPEAKER_00]: De actualizar algunos procesos, de empezar a buscar ahorros en temas internos dentro de la compañía de manejo de la información, automatización de etapas y procesos para que todo sea un poco más fluido y les permita a ustedes tomar un poco más de decisiones y enfocarse más en planeación que en elaboración, por así decirlo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, Andrea me ha contado un poco de la compañía, lo que ustedes hacen.
[SPEAKER_00]: El crecimiento que tuvo Trixx y la forma que vos la desarrollaste.
[SPEAKER_00]: Igualmente me gustaría conocer también un poco más de la compañía, entender de pronto cuál es la logística de usted interna de la compañía.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cuáles son los procesos de trabajo para ver cómo los podemos ayudar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Digamos que yo hoy en día estoy comenzando una compañía con mi hermano, mi hermano vive en Bruselas.
[SPEAKER_00]: En la cual vamos a hacer unos, pues estamos dedicándonos a hacer consultorías apoyados mucho con temas de inteligencia artificial.
[SPEAKER_00]: para automatizar procesos dentro de las compañías para agilizar digamos que tareas manuales que pasen de ser una tarea manual a una tarea computacional todo pues como apoyado a diferentes herramientas tecnológicas también hemos notado que muchas compañías que compran mucho software tienen muchas herramientas tecnológicas pero no le sacan el provecho 100% entonces es buscar la manera como de cerrar esa brecha entre lo que tienen hoy en día las compañías sin necesidad de comprar nuevos productos
[SPEAKER_00]: Para que el trabajo sea mucho más fácil para los empleados.
[SPEAKER_02]: Una de mis preocupaciones que acabo de... el marzo anoche precisamente estaba pensando es... los nuevos métodos que están utilizando a nivel mundial en cuanto a la inteligencia artificial.
[SPEAKER_02]: En la logística está muy definido ya.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya no va a haber mucho que descubrir porque
[SPEAKER_02]: El poder de la mano de obra en este tipo de negocio no puede desaparecer, se necesita 100%.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si te vas a una compañía que está líder mundial en logística, que ya ingresó a algo súper relevante, que no sé a dónde puede ir más, es Amazon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahorita ellos acaban de contratar
[SPEAKER_02]: Hector Leyla,Costco Reunión presencial en Trixx Logistics en Tijuana sobre logística cross-border, contenedores CBP,Amazon,Walmart,Cartagena,Luis,Ricardo,Damian,Maria,Hector,Damian,Maria,Leonisa,Amazon,Walmart,Costco Reunión presencial en Trixx Logistics en Tijuana
[SPEAKER_02]: En Latinoamérica no lo ha podido lograr por las regulaciones que hay en México, por todos los sindicatos y por todas esas cosas, pero sí me gustaría a mí en lo personal saber un poco más cómo poder aplicar nosotros, si tenemos un sistema bueno que a la gente le da flojera,
[SPEAKER_02]: Bueno, a nuestros clientes les da porjera o no sé por qué son apáticos de no utilizarlo, a lo mejor porque no es amigable, a lo mejor porque ahora ya ves que con un clic queremos todo y hemos estado batallando con algunos clientes, pero tengo entendido que lo tenemos muy completo, tengo entendido.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí no nos hemos profundizado en todo eso, pero sí quisiera yo saber un poquito más de lo que es las nuevas modalidades
[SPEAKER_02]: Este enfocado a la logística.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nosotros contamos con una empresa americana en transporte, en bodegas y hacemos diferentes procesos a nuestra manera.
[SPEAKER_02]: No te puedo decir que tengo gente capacitada pero sí tengo gente muy trabajadora que a lo mejor ya se convierte en un vicio.
[SPEAKER_02]: El buen trabajador ya no quiere
[SPEAKER_02]: No quiere recibir, no quiere ser.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nos ha costado mucho trabajo que utilicen las herramientas que nosotros proporcionamos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tuvimos un switch, un cambio muy fuerte de lo que hacíamos manual a lo que hacemos ahora con una computadora, con una tablet, con sistemas que fue Marilena aplicando y que nos costó trabajo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mucho trabajo educar a los trabajadores.
[SPEAKER_02]: Estamos ingresando en el
[SPEAKER_02]: En el transporte Americano y en el Mexicano y también nos está costando mucho trabajo porque pues se oponen a las nuevas tecnologías, ellos se quedan supervisados.
[SPEAKER_02]: A resumen, a final de cuentas, lo que nosotros queremos, yo no me quiero ahorrar a lo mejor 100 dólares o 100 pesos, lo que quiero es tener las respuestas en el momento.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si pasó algo, quiero saber por qué, cómo,
[SPEAKER_02]: Y donde cometimos el error.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y porque ya hemos visto varias cosas, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Respecto al rendimiento del diésel, tenemos otra persona que nos bloquea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todos son muy buenos trabajadores para mí porque los conozco de más de 22 años.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero con el tiempo, pues tú sabes que ya se va haciendo un vicio.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, lo que yo quisiera es, tenemos Marilena y yo un plan, digamos, rústico.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si se puede utilizar la palabra, en que uno de mis socios va a ingresar a la compañía en el 2026 por medio de una mesa inversionista.
[SPEAKER_02]: En la inversión que va a salir, yo quedé con Marilena en que me voy a salir en el operativo y ya quita todos sus vicios que ya los trae.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muy arraigados, como muy fuertes.
[SPEAKER_02]: La bodega americana, la bodega en Guadalajara, problemas...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo no traigo problemas de trabajo, traigo problemas de actitudes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces a veces los problemas de actitudes se van reflejando al final de cuentas en una mala relación entre el personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si sale una orden de aquí que todos creen que porque a lo mejor Marilena era encargada de todo,
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Es que es ocurrencia de ella?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, es ocurrencia mía.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces todo lo mal interpreto, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Y a raíz de todo esto han subido fricciones en el personal, que es lo que no me gusta.
[SPEAKER_02]: Otra de las situaciones también es que sí me gustaría como tener más orden en la bodega.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perdón.
[SPEAKER_02]: Adelante.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bueno.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_04]: ¿Es la bodega de los Ángeles?
[SPEAKER_05]: Empezamos por la calle.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esa bodega está muy pequeña para el espacio que tenemos, entonces tenemos subcontratado otra bodega.
[SPEAKER_05]: El servicio de otra bodega, no el espacio de la bodega.
[SPEAKER_00]: No tienen arrendada la bodega sino el servicio de guardar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Quien saca los contenedores del puerto, estos puertos llegan de Long Beach.
[SPEAKER_05]: Llegan de China.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tenemos cuatro clientes que les llevan contenedores de Long Beach.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hector se refiere al cliente Jan, es un cliente que quiere sacar su visa de inversionista porque su visa
[SPEAKER_05]: Él es venezolano, chinos, nacido en Venezuela, emigrado mexicano.
[SPEAKER_05]: De varias nacionalidades.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, él va a sacar su visa inversionista.
[SPEAKER_05]: Perdón.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, sigue, sigue, sigue.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y traemos un proyecto en el 27 de crecer, bueno, ya estamos ahorita creciendo, pero hemos sido muy precavidos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muy precavidos en que yo digo siempre a Marilena, a ver, yo no voy a cometer el error
[SPEAKER_02]: En un momento de trabajo que te va bien, ya por eso yo ya me voy a los extremos y no lo quiero hacer, hemos sido muy precavidos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero ese es un proyecto donde podamos rentar o comprar una bodega unas cinco veces más que donde estamos y tener al personal adecuado.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nosotros estamos trabajando sub-arrendando un servicio que creo que es bueno.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero... Con lo que se le paga, se puede rentar y podemos hacerlo, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo también no soy de los que digo, no, yo en el año me voy a ahorrar tanto y mejor lo hubiera...
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: De todos modos ese dinero ni lo ves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Al final de cuentas, ni lo ves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque si así fueran los ahorros y las inversiones en cualquier empresa,
[SPEAKER_02]: Todos fuéramos multimillonarios.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces lo que sí nos interesa mucho es si sabemos cómo trabajar, sabemos cómo hacer las cosas, sabemos cómo tratar a la gente y al final de cuentas pues el que acerca a los clientes con el que negocio soy yo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero también eso no es sano para un negocio.
[SPEAKER_02]: A veces yo con el tiempo he estado perdiendo la tolerancia con los clientes y sinceramente con un telefonazo los mando mucho por un tubo y ya no vuelvo a aparecer.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya no les doy el servicio otra vez.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si quieren regresar Contigo al Servicio les cojo más caro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y regresan porque saben que nosotros no robamos, no decimos mentiras como en los mandamientos y no mandamos
[SPEAKER_02]: No andan nunca me meto en algo personal con los clientes, todo es comercial, laboral.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todo esto es comercial, todo es comercial.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, si lo que más nos interesa es ver una mirada de por fuera y que nos digan hacia dónde a lo mejor.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Cómo?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Cómo está?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo sí sé cómo está cambiando el mundo en la logística.
[SPEAKER_02]: En eso estoy al 100% me considero.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todos los días estoy viendo lo que están haciendo las empresas a nivel mundial.
[SPEAKER_02]: No aquí nacional tanto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque yo ya sé aquí lo nacional.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aquí nos defendemos de la violencia, nos defendemos de la extorsión, nos defendemos del robo, nos defendemos de la autoridad.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso yo ya lo sé.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero lo que quiero hacer es, no quiero caer en empresas que tienen toda la tecnología y que tienen que ir a tocar puertas para pedir trabajo porque ya no tienen trabajo y no pueden mantener esa maquinaria de camiones, de personal, de compromisos laborales.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso hasta ahorita no lo hemos cometido nosotros.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hemos tenido malas rachas pero
[SPEAKER_02]: Hablantes en español.
[SPEAKER_02]: Por fuera, también no tenemos ningún problema.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya sabemos cuáles son nuestros defectos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Por aquí han desfilado unas cuatro o cinco personas y algunos nos dicen que yo correría fulanito y correría así, pero para correr no hay la opción.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si tú me dices corre primero al que tienes ahí porque es un tirano, sí, pero no ha funcionado.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si vos no querés tampoco que te cambien la forma de la compañía como las han venido construyendo ustedes de un momento a otro, un tercero pues.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, si.
[SPEAKER_00]: De acuerdo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces este, entonces si quiero que, si me, a menos que nos propongas, si nos propones algo, lo platicamos, no te puedo decir ya que ahorita lo voy a aceptar, pero lo podemos platicar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hector Leyándose a Marilena y a mí y vemos de qué forma nos puedes apoyar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo nunca estoy en contra de saber más.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso para mí siempre ha sido muy importante.
[SPEAKER_02]: No lo que yo diga siempre va a ser lo correcto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Estoy abierto a la crítica y sobre todo a mejorar lo que
[SPEAKER_02]: Lo que hemos pues construido, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Que cuando te quedes, ¿cómo lo hemos construido?
Es la relación de cajas y camiones.
Estas son las cajas que se tienen.
McKinney,Trixx.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y estos son los camiones que se tenían y más o menos con veintidós.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo creo que lo que tenemos que... Aquí compré diez más.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, pero apenas se están pidiendo los BIN, por eso no están ahí los números de los BIN.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Son los que acabas de pedir, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita Miguel está pidiendo los DIN para ya relacionarlos, entonces van a ser diez más.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si traemos muchas cositas ahí, nosotros a lo mejor quedas a decir bueno como sobreviviste, como esto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eh mira, hemos sobrevivido a punta de como se dice vulgarmente chingazos y por otra ha resistido también a esas malas, muy malas rachas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero ahorita que tenemos buenas, estamos aprovechando ese boom.
[SPEAKER_02]: No me la creo, no creas tú que me la creo.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, me estoy preparando para el día de mañana porque yo siempre pienso el día de mañana y si cambia toda esta situación económica, bueno, ya tenemos cómo soportar eso pues.
[SPEAKER_02]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_02]: En vez de tanta deuda la vamos reduciendo sin ninguna ganancia personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, no creas tú que tengo una ganancia y voy dos meses a viajar por el mundo o me compro un carro del año que es impagable.
[SPEAKER_02]: No hago eso.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso no lo hago.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me gusta vivir bien, me gusta que toda la gente que trabaja conmigo viva bien, esté bien y sobre todo que me guste el trabajo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso es lo que yo más quiero.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque durante tantos años lo que hago es lo que me gusta y como me gusta lo disfruto y como lo disfruto no la paso bien.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, en resumidas cuentas eso es lo que nosotros somos, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno Miguel aparte en cuestión de necesidades ahorita como ya se invirtió como ves ya hay más de 70 cajas y más de 20 camiones el tener más equipo implica que tenemos que cumplir con más requisitos y más inspecciones.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces creo que si no llevamos como un control ya de comunidad, la inspección trimestral, semestral, si tienen las placas, si tienen los permis, o sea, si cuentan con todo, entonces como que todo eso no lo tenemos que tener como en papel deshaclado sino ya... Porque, ajá, agregarle que tenemos esto, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Esto, esto para ti.
[SPEAKER_02]: Más aparte tenemos vehículos que utilizamos, unos diez vehículos que se utilizan con personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, señor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Más aparte, flotillas de carros que andan ahí entre personales, o sea, yo cuido mucho el equipo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es lo que más cuido, el equipo, porque es lo que nos da de comer.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, todo tiene que tener un orden y necesitamos un orden en todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Estoy hablando más de 120 vehículos que tenemos.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, entre desde uno que costó 250 mil dólares, que son 10, hasta el más barato, a lo mejor,
[SPEAKER_02]: Que hacemos intercambio, hey préstame ese carro y te lo cambio por este y que vale diez mil dólares en la barra.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces... O sea, como que esa parte en cuestión de equipo que esté toda digitalizada, con imágenes, con fotos, con el servicio que se le ha dado, con los mantenimientos, o sea, todas las partes que se le están comprando, por ejemplo, el camión 8 ahorita es el invertido, yo creo que más de lo que cuesta.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿El 8 cuál es?
[SPEAKER_05]: El 8 a lo mejor ya lo deberíamos de cambiar por uno de los que se le compraron a Diego en México que circula en Estados Unidos hacer ese switch.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿El Internacional?
[SPEAKER_05]: El Internacional, el 8 ya lo metiste.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿El Internacional es el DECAP?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, el 8, el camión 8.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué es el DECAP?
[SPEAKER_05]: El Volvo 8.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ese ya se le metió dinero.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero entonces como ya veo una estadística alarmante, esta unidad ya se le metió más de lo que cuesta valorar si se...
[SPEAKER_05]: Si se echa o si se sigue invirtiendo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces como que todas las unidades tener como un expediente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Una hoja de vida del vehículo, de lo que ha hecho.
[SPEAKER_05]: Todos los consumos que tiene.
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque tenemos como el papeleo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Obviamente tenemos una persona que le gusta mucho
[SPEAKER_03]: La hoja.
[SPEAKER_03]: A todos en esta oficina les encantan las hojas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Si entras a mi lugar está lleno de hojas.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea como que hacer esa transición de papel a digital y de con un clic meter yo la unidad este el Volvo 01 y saber
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Dónde estaba?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Qué ha hecho?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Los recorridos?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Contenimientos?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Cuándo se le vencen sus inspecciones ecológicas,mecánicas?
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Cuándo se le vencen las placas?
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, eso en cuanto al equipo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y hay otra parte que también
[SPEAKER_05]: Me gustaría que se tomara en consideración para todos los contenedores que llegan del puerto, como que también los tienen las personas, los que son de China, los que son de Carlos, los que son de China, como que unificar toda esa información y ver todo el gasto que genera.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si traemos como tres operaciones, una acá por Houston, una en Long Beach y otra acá por Mexicali, entonces traemos en tren, traemos tren,
[SPEAKER_02]: Barco y terrestre.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y sí, efectivamente, cada quien, por ejemplo, aquí yo hago una reunión, alguien me reporta lo de tren, alguien me reporta lo de mar, alguien me reporta lo... es un portal... Y, por ejemplo, el gasto que se genera, o sea, el gasto que se genera del broker, el gasto que se genera del puerto, el gasto que se genera del... este... de Daguan, el gasto que se... o sea, todo el gasto que se genera
[SPEAKER_05]: En cuanto al movimiento de ese contenedor, ¿en qué caja se cargó?, ¿por dónde cruzó?, ¿el tiempo que tardó en trasladarse?
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que son dos temas así como pilares.
[SPEAKER_02]: Te dirías que, digo, a reserva, como cualquier análisis, tienes que saber
[SPEAKER_02]: La operación.
[SPEAKER_02]: No me atrevería a decirte... Es más, no te he ni preguntado qué haces.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si te has fijado, no te dejo ni hablar.
[SPEAKER_00]: No te preocupes, yo estoy aquí para escucharlos y saber qué es lo que necesitan.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es muy importante que no te deje hablar porque es como cuando vas al doctor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Primero le platicas al doctor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hablantes en español.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Me explico?
[SPEAKER_02]: O me das tu especialidad o me dices, pues no importa, yo lo puedo solucionar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces es como los doctores, porque si te dejo hablar...
[SPEAKER_00]: Ahí ya te patean de uno, te sacan por el lado.
[SPEAKER_02]: No me interesa, tengo todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: El arrogante siempre te dice tengo todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo no lo hago.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y te vas a sentir mal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces mejor te platico mis problemas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si puedes, nos puedes ayudar.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, está súper bien.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si no, nos recomiendas cómo nos puedes ayudar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro que sí, señor.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, por mí está súper bien la dinámica que estamos manejando.
[SPEAKER_00]: La podemos mantener y ya al final, si quieren, yo les cuento un poquito más o menos cómo es la forma de trabajar de nosotros para ver cómo les podemos ayudar precisamente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, he notado, como vos decís, hay dos pilares importantes de información, que es la información
[SPEAKER_00]: La información de los camiones y la información de los contenedores, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_00]: Y también me mencionaste algo que me parece que también es muy importante de pronto como retomarlo, es el tema de la fricción que hay dentro del equipo por temas de la información, entiendo, porque pues como dijo Andrea ahorita hay muchas personas que están acostumbradas al papel, otras que de pronto pueden estar acostumbradas a las pantallas y creo que eso puede generar mucha fricción, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_02]: Dices los grupos esos de WhatsApp que son buenos porque ya es algo más personalizado pero que a veces no pongo, a veces también Marilena está como en 15 grupos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_03]: Es que Ricardo aquí nadie usa correo electrónico, ya es que como muchas empresas utilizan que vas copiando aquí en los puros WhatsApp.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y también otra cosa es por ejemplo cada, como tenemos algunos
[SPEAKER_05]: Proveedores de transporte, el asignarle ya una carga a que proveedor se le diga el número de chofer, el número de placas, entonces a veces hay como esta, a veces se confunde a quién le vas a asignar el contenedor, qué transportista va a mover el contenedor.
[SPEAKER_05]: Eso es otra cosa que hay que... que hoy lo estamos haciendo muy manual, muy... ¿Cómo viene?
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, aparte...
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, un contenedor, un camión se puede ir, tú lo pagaste y nos damos cuenta.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, ¿cuántos fueron?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Quién sabe?
[SPEAKER_02]: Se lo chingan y ya pagamos, ya todo, o sea, tiene que haber un control.
[SPEAKER_02]: Este ya llegó, o sea, cuál entregaste, cuál esto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya es que a la hora que pedimos cuentas de Carlos Muñoz, de otro cabrón, pagan en efectivo y traemos un... Y los en el pago, luego nos dicen qué contenedores son los que están pagando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Exactamente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, ahí ya no hay...
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, traemos ya un... aquí, hazte cuenta, traemos un callo.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Crees que conoces un callo?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, sí, sí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Por más que vayas al podólogo...
[SPEAKER_02]: Ese está ahí todavía.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahí está.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lo que tienes que hacer es que corta la pierna.
[SPEAKER_02]: O vas con el especialista y le dicen, ¿qué hago para que no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pues cómplese zapatos nuevos, tres zapatos con dos años, dos mil.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tiene que salir un callo, tómate calcetines y cómprate diez pares de zapatos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, eso es lo que nos traemos nosotros varios callos aquí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Varios callos, entonces, digo, tampoco no voy a decir voy a bajar la cortina y ya se acabó el negocio.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, tengo que...
[SPEAKER_05]: Esa transición, ahorita que hay más equipo y que no queremos que se salga las manos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita está en nuestras manos pero se puede salir del control.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se va a salir.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita se acaban de comprar 10 camiones más y se acaban de comprar... 20 cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, 30 cajas más.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Con cajas se refieren a contenedores?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, a la caja seca.
[SPEAKER_00]: A la caja seca aquella.
[SPEAKER_00]: Este es el contenedor y esta es la caja.
[SPEAKER_05]: Estas son rentaz, tenemos que hacer Rentaz.
[SPEAKER_00]: Son de temperatura estas cajas o no necesariamente?
[SPEAKER_00]: Solamente secas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Estos son de 40 a 45 y las cajas son de 53 pies.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces estos contenedores...
[SPEAKER_05]: No te preocupe, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Adelante, adelante.
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Y cualquier información que necesites?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, yo creo que, a ver, lo que de pronto lo comentamos, André, pues hablamos el sábado un poco y por lo que veo hay como diferentes temas a tocar y diferentes personas que están involucradas con los diferentes temas, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo creo que sería identificar de pronto las oportunidades que hay en los diferentes equipos y hablar con cada uno de los equipos a ver
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Cuáles son los dolores de cabeza que ellos tienen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces André me comentó que ya tenían unos dolores de cabeza, más que dolores de cabeza, eran como...
[SPEAKER_00]: Unas cartas portes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exacto.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unas situaciones.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se pueden hacer automáticamente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, ok, perfecto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mira, déjame...
[SPEAKER_05]: Adelante, adelante, por favor.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, sí, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esta es la bodega en Los Ángeles, que digo, ahorita está demasiado pequeña, pero como comenta Héctor, o sea, el expandirte no es nada más ir a rentar un espacio.
[SPEAKER_05]: De hecho, se han buscado muchísimas bodegas y en...
[SPEAKER_05]: Hemos pasado así como en Los Ángeles en estos años como etapa de mucha demanda de trabajo y en ocasiones no hay bodegas disponibles.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita parece que hay muchas bodegas disponibles pero con ciertas restricciones.
[SPEAKER_05]: Algunas no cumplen con la altura.
[SPEAKER_05]: Otras han estado en zonas en las que el horario es restringido.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, x y. Ahorita hay todo lo que se está esperando es como
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que se decidió el contratar a alguien externo, te digo, para poder hacer descargas de contenedores porque llegó un punto en el que quien nos sacaba los contenedores del puerto los tenía en su patio y ya el contenedor sale del puerto y tiene ciertos días para regresarlo porque sino se genera una demora.
[SPEAKER_04]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y lo que provocó ese momento es que nos llegaron muchos contenedores, no teníamos el espacio para descargarlos aquí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y empezó a hacerse demoras pero de miles de horas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y de repente, has de contar, el señor este tenía los contenedores aquí y seguía poniendo acá y el sacar estos para él era imposible.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y esos causaban demoras impresionantes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y además de la demora que se le paga al puerto, pues el cliente necesita esa mercancía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, ahorita tenemos dos personas que sacan contenedores del puerto.
[SPEAKER_05]: La persona que lo saca tiene dos bodegas donde nos llegan, además de aquí, en dos lugares más.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nada más que ahí nada más podemos tener a un cliente, un cliente yan que saca los contenedores después.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cuando descargan estos, estos se forman unos 26, 27 tarimas con estos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque si te fijas la caja es grande, entonces vas a otro espacio y estos ya se van directamente a México, a la Ciudad de México.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y la razón por la cual hay una... pues porque se acumulan tanto y no los pueden despachar digamos que de manera inmediata es... Para empezar aquí tiene un horario que siempre le he dicho a Héctor, tiene un solo turno.
[SPEAKER_05]: Le digo que para una bodega pues un turno es muy poco.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro, mínimo dos o veinticuatro o siete idealmente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero entonces...
[SPEAKER_05]: Desde ahí yo le estaba haciendo como conciencia de que tenemos que tener dos turnos.
[SPEAKER_03]: Porque te has tiempo perdido porque nos están comiendo y nadie más.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aparte comen todos juntos, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero bueno, porque también cargan y descargan todos juntos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces estaban entrando a las 10 de la mañana y saliendo a las 6 de la tarde.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que ¿quién entra a las 10 de la mañana?
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces tienen muy poquito tiempo que están entrando a las 9 de la mañana.
[SPEAKER_05]: Imagínate en una bodega entrar a las 10 de la mañana, todo tu tiempo muerto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces yo le digo, tenemos que tener un horario de que sea, no sé, como de 7 a 3 y de 3 a 7, o sea, aprovechar más el espacio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero bueno, ahorita que ya se compró más equipo que va a estar circulando y que hay manera de...
[SPEAKER_05]: Iba, rentó aquí a la vuelta de la bodega hay un terreno que una persona le rentó y le robaron dos contenedores.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, no te puedo creer.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay mismo en Los Ángeles.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dos contenedores enteros.
[SPEAKER_05]: Enteros con todo el contenedor.
[SPEAKER_05]: Después uno de los contenedores crea GPS y apareció el contenedor vacío ya por allá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ahorita se paga un guardia todas las noches para que esté ahí el pendiente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y el tracking de los contenedores que tú dices que se están acumulando es uno de los problemas que ustedes tienen, que no hay como una forma de seguimiento.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita tenemos Samsara que es la compañía que... Samsara, con él tenemos lo que es el monitoreo de los camiones.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esta es una compañía, justo ayer aprendí a descargar los videos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y nos dimos cuenta que no estaba prendido la grabación.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hoy la de Samsara me dijo que quedó activado el escuchar la conversación de los camioneros.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hoy me dijo buenos días.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mira Helena, ya me dice Helena.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tenía configurada la plataforma para que no grabara audio, pero ya la encendimos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y es una cámara que está dentro de la cabina del camionero.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ayer ya...
[SPEAKER_05]: Descargué unos videos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aquí aprendí ya a descargarlos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y por ejemplo, este trae la cámara apagada.
[SPEAKER_05]: La interna.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, por ejemplo, pasa algo en carretera, aquí lo asaltan y pues el conductor...
[SPEAKER_05]: La trae tapada.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, no, es que la tiene, sí, creo que está como nublada, exacto, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Si la trae tapada, pues eso no lo podemos estar permitiendo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Doctor, quiero una persona que esté monitoreando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y te fijas, no tiene audio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Digo, puede ir cantando, hablando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, ahorita, justo ayer... ¿Cómo es que no tiene audio?
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque lo tenía apagado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ya pregunté.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, no tenía el audio y estaba desactivado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ayer lo vi con ella.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que ayer asaltaron a alguien de, bueno, le paró la policía a alguien en México de otra compañía y nos mandó esto.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, se escucha todo el audio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Como lo para la policía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces dice, Hector, ¿por qué no tenemos esto?
[SPEAKER_05]: Y ya investigué, ellos, este es Tamsara también.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, lo para la policía.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y ahí todo el audio y toda la conversación queda...
[SPEAKER_05]: Sesenta mil pesos los sacó.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Por qué?
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque trae las cortinas, cortinas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Total, bueno.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, esta es la... Y aquí tú quieres saber cuándo pusieron gasolina, cuándo quitaron gas, o sea, porque aquí te puedes saber si pusiste gasolina, si no pusiste gasolina, hasta traer todo el control.
[SPEAKER_05]: Quiero una persona que esté monitoreando 24-7, que le hable al chofer, oye, prende la cámara.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mira, tenemos las dos órdenes.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Y estas cámaras la tienen solamente para los camiones grandes o para los ciento y punta?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, también para los vehículos, pero los vehículos locales, este...
[SPEAKER_05]: Por ejemplo, ahorita tenemos a los...
[SPEAKER_05]: El Centra, este es Centra, que también tiene la cámara apagada siempre.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este...
[SPEAKER_05]: El centro de CBP está prendido.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tenemos otros que están, los Versa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si tienen casi 100 carros, entonces siempre con monitoreo constante.
[SPEAKER_05]: El audio pues apenas recién, pero no hay una persona que esté así como viendo las alertas de seguridad y dónde está.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aparte las cajas que tenemos de Makini, ellos tienen otra plataforma.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces tenemos cajas rentadas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Que sí tienen otro sistema de monitoreo pero nada más es para cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Algunas cajas sí tienen una cámara dentro del camión.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y otras cajas nada más tienen como su rastreo satelital.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces te tiene que entrar a esa plataforma más a la plataforma de McKinney.
[SPEAKER_05]: McKinney es una compañía grande de Estados Unidos que renta las cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y se tienen como 40 cajas rentables.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita estamos empezando como la transición a esta compañía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Estamos empezando la transición.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita se regresaron cuatro cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, una, un chofer la dañó.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que Trixx tiene muchas cajas y subcontrata el servicio de la persona que maneja el camión, al camionero para que las mueva.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues Trixx tiene...
[SPEAKER_05]: Siete choferes en Estados Unidos y el resto de los movimientos lo hace una compañía.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y los movimientos, los siete choferes que ustedes tienen son en trayectos largos?
[SPEAKER_05]: De Verno, California.
[SPEAKER_05]: Su base es el Paso, Texas y llegan a Verno, California.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ese es el mapa.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Y ya los recorridos que son un poco más cortos son subcontratados?
[SPEAKER_05]: En Estados Unidos, como los choferes son mexicanos, se llama cabotaje el que un chofer mexicano haga una recolección por fuera del recorrido habitual.
[SPEAKER_05]: Unos libros electrónicos en los camiones en el que deben supuestamente manejar ocho horas, no traer sobrepes, o sea, ciertas restricciones de acuerdo al Departamento de Transporte de Estados Unidos, que es el DOT, que es el que te regula todas las inspecciones, el que tienes que pasar por básculas, el que te regula todo el transporte en Estados Unidos, y hay un... cada parada que le hacen, por ejemplo, que nos han parado un chofer y que no sabe inglés, o que traía un foco roto, que no tenía el extintor,
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay un semáforo de... Hasta que llega el rojo que ya te multan o te prohíben la... Y te quitan tu permiso de DOT como transportista, te pueden perder.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y también cuando contratas la compañía de seguros...
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos ven tu historial.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tu score y te pueden subir el premium o no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ajá, te dan una tarifa de acuerdo al riesgo que para ellos represente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y los subcontratados son para hacer esos trayectos que los mexicanos no pueden hacer.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, es para cubrir con nuestra capacidad.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah bueno.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita estamos en búsqueda de choferes americanos porque
[SPEAKER_05]: Ya les están quitando visas a los choferes mexicanos porque pues se los han cachado de que o no, no, a lo mejor en su momento sí hicieron alguna entrega local o a lo mejor este no marcaron bien su salida del país.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro, y además es un riesgo para ustedes porque también les reduce el score, pues en el caso que no el inglés o que cualquier inconveniente que tenga probablemente soluciones más fáciles.
[SPEAKER_05]: De hecho ahorita se compraron 10 camiones y estamos en búsqueda de choferes y
[SPEAKER_05]: Los sueldos en Trixx son muy competitivos que si comparas lo que le estás pagando un chofer mexicano a un chofer americano pues equivale prácticamente lo mismo.
[SPEAKER_05]: La diferencia es que un chofer mexicano a lo mejor si se aventara a manejar más de las ocho horas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el americano a las ocho horas se orilla y ya no le sigue hasta cumplir su descanso para continuar el trayecto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y también, por ejemplo, el chofer americano, si se le tiene un daño, se les compuso un foco, ahí en Phoenix te va a decir ven a resolvérnoslo el foco.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el mexicano va a ir y le pone algo en la regla y avanza.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esas son las diferencias, pero que claro que queremos hacer este cambio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, aquí llegan
[SPEAKER_05]: Que en parte esos también ajustes de pequeños que pueden pasar en carretera que ustedes quieren también tenerlos dentro de la hoja de vida los de las... Sí, sí, sí, porque también a veces nos escriben a las once de la noche pagar una llanta ponchada o pagar una banda o pagar, o sea, se tiene que hacer ese pago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y les escriben por donde ese tipo que es como de comunicaciones cortas, es por WhatsApp, por una plataforma interna.
[SPEAKER_05]: Por WhatsApp, por WhatsApp, ahí nos ponen en refacciones, este, pagar este...
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay un grupo de refacciones.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Cuántos grupos tienen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo estoy en muchos, yo en México.
[SPEAKER_03]: Todos los tenemos en Colombia.
[SPEAKER_05]: Por ejemplo aquí el jueves me apoyan con esto, una llanta.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cambiar las bolsas de aire.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y puede ser en Estados Unidos o en México.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se puede componer en cualquier lado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí esto.
[SPEAKER_05]: El jueves, bueno era 2.30 y eso no estuvo mal, pero el domingo
[SPEAKER_05]: El domingo creo que mandaron algo, o sea, les tienes que resolverlo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Los choferos nunca traen dinero y nunca... O sea, cualquier día, el domingo a las 3 de la tarde.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se les ponen chuna llanta, o sea, estás en carretera y pues sucede todo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, a nosotros aquí está Trixx Logistics en Vernon, California.
[SPEAKER_05]: Salen los contenedores del Long Beach y hacen el recorrido hasta acá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y cruzan por Chihuahua, Durango, Zacatecas, y unos van a México y otros llegan acá a Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este es nuestro centro de distribución, está en Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Y este recorrido lo harían ya...?
[SPEAKER_05]: Este lo hace un camión ya mexicano.
[SPEAKER_05]: La caja la cruzan y acá hay otro conductor.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y eso es otro que tenemos, aquí pagamos a los custodios, aquí también están en Samsara los custodios que van siguiendo a los camiones porque pues los robos en carretera en México están también... Sí, mucho más elevado que en Estados Unidos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y ahorita se está cruzando también por Galveston, Galveston está por aquí, en Houston, por aquí abajo, entonces está cruzando Houston, se vienen por San Antonio,
[SPEAKER_05]: Cruzan por piedras negras y están llegando a Monterrey.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y esta ruta ahorita le gustó al cliente y a lo mejor la usamos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita Héctor ve el lunes a Houston a verlo de un almacén para empezar a descargar aquí y empezar a lo mejor a traer contenedores de Houston a México.
[SPEAKER_05]: Que el trayecto sería un poco más corto así que traerte a lo mejor todo desde acá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claro, todo eso es una lucha.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tenemos un cliente que está hasta acá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay otro cliente en León, va a Querétaro, a Morelia, muy poco.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el seguimiento de mencionadas que tienen la plataforma de Samsara.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Maquini tiene una propia?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Qué otros software utilizan ustedes dentro de la compañía como para hacer tracking de, no solamente de los camiones, sino de los paquetes o de la información?
[SPEAKER_05]: Lo de los paquetes, mira, yo cuando entré aquí lo hacían así en una hoja.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, lo hacían primero en una hoja.
[SPEAKER_05]: Subían todo y no se sabía nada.
[SPEAKER_05]: No tenía el computador en Los Ángeles.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y después yo empecé y dije, pues aunque sea en una hoja, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿En un exceso?
[SPEAKER_05]: Y después, no, en una hoja de mano.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, de mano.
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque sabía mucho.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues se perdían cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces hace tres años contratamos, híjole, ya teníamos un proveedor que de verdad yo ya lo tenía en Los Ángeles, estaba instalando el programa, algo no me gustó, o sea, teníamos todo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo creo que estuvimos trabajando con él unos par de meses.
[SPEAKER_05]: Estando en Los Ángeles cuando me estaba instalando le dije sabes que no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah sí, hubo algo que te dio mala vibra.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y entonces yo contacté a un compañero con el que trabajaba en otra empresa, que en paz descanse hace tres años murió, y él me empezó a apoyar y consiguió esta compañía en Miami, se llama Trucking Premium.
[SPEAKER_05]: Así se llama, Trucking Premium.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces él, de acuerdo a nuestras necesidades, empezó...
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué es paquetería?
[SPEAKER_05]: Enséñale lo de... Es que en sí la mercancía no es nuestra.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí, usted solamente es un transportista.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tenemos clientes que mandan para ellos y tenemos clientes que tienen sus clientes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_03]: Que tiene su propia coquetería.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mire, enséñale, por ejemplo, todo de USA.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, esos clientes que reciben sus productos por medio de un número de tracking, o sea, que ya te viene de la tienda de... Sí, es como si yo fuera Amazon y les dijera a ustedes, yo ya no sé para qué ir a tal parte.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ya estoy subcontratando su...
[SPEAKER_05]: Ella es todo de usted, es un cliente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ella, sus clientes compran en cualquier tienda que te puedas imaginar en Estados Unidos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Desde un, no sé... Es como un P.O.
[SPEAKER_03]: Box.
Es un P.O.
[SPEAKER_03]: Para el cliente, no para todos, sino para el cliente, es un P.O.
[SPEAKER_03]: Box dominicano.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces con ellos para tener la trazabilidad de su paquete,
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues lo que queríamos es seguir que su número de tracking con el que el cliente le está dando seguimiento desde el momento que hizo la compra hasta el momento.
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que tú siempre le vas dando tu seguimiento a tu paquete.
[SPEAKER_05]: Al paquete para saber dónde estaba.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces para no generar un número diferente nosotros para entrar a nuestro almacén se decidió que se escanea el tracking de origen y se sigue conservando.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces en el
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué es esto?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Instagram o qué?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, esa es su página web.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que en su Instagram no tiene.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, hay de todas las tiendas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero nada más en Instagram para que vean como una idea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos le dicen a tu cliente, bueno, déjame esta hoja.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos le dicen a tu cliente, regístrate.
[SPEAKER_05]: Regístrate así.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cuando vayas a hacer una cosa y los contactan,
[SPEAKER_05]: Y Andrea también tiene una paquetería pero no le da seguimiento.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se llama Dortudo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Todo de USA, la dirección de Vernon, el número de teléfono y les pedimos mucho que le pongan el nombre, apellido y después todo de USA para saber que el paquete es de esta compañía y se pueda registrar ahorita cuando entres al sistema lo puedas registrar correctamente.
[SPEAKER_05]: No todos lo hacen pero bueno esa es la idea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos ya consiguen sus clientes, les llega el paquete a la bodega
[SPEAKER_05]: Y ahora sí me regreso al sistema.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y eso se registra aquí, como paquetes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, esa es la relación de los paquetes que se han registrado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ya llevas como una relación de todos los paquetes.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, va llegando y se va registrando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el cliente, todo de USA, de este mismo sistema, tiene un acceso únicamente...
[SPEAKER_05]: A la versión de ustedes.
[SPEAKER_05]: En tiempo real puede estar viendo los paquetes que están registrando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Que ya ingresó a Trixx Logistics.
[SPEAKER_05]: Que están aquí en bodega, que está Silvia registrando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este es el área de la paquetería.
[SPEAKER_05]: No la veo, pero aquí llegan todos los paquetes y aquí en esta área ella va registrando todo lo de todo de USA.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces tiene una computadora y va registrando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esa es la parte de paquetes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ya es bien fácil saber dónde está.
[SPEAKER_00]: Que digamos que este que es el más individualizado está funcionando de una manera más organizada.
[SPEAKER_05]: Está funcionando de una manera más organizada.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y lo que no trae tracking ya lo registramos aquí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí le pones listar y aquí puedes crear tu guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aquí ya registras, es Trixx, aquí son el cliente de división, estos son los clientes de división que tenemos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Eliges el cliente de división para seguir con el tema todo de USA, pues eliges todo de USA.
[SPEAKER_05]: Quien lo manda, si es todo de USA, aquí tenemos, nada más que aquí han registrado 20 veces al mismo cliente, entonces tenemos como que está muy inflada la base de datos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Todo de USA con USA mayúscula, minúscula, espacios en espacios.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces a veces al momento de querer hacer un reporte,
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues tienes que buscar como en cinco reportes todos los todos de USA que existen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aquí están los destinatarios.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí puedes coger, no sé, yo pongo un nombre, Paola.
[SPEAKER_05]: Que ahí sí hay muchísimos más allá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y también están repetidos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Escoges uno, le pones el tipo de, si es un sobre, la descripción, la descripción, el peso.
[SPEAKER_05]: El valor es obligatorio, el largo, alto, por ancho.
[SPEAKER_05]: La fórmula en la que Trixx registra cobra por medidas, no cobra por peso, que es algo que está mal, porque hay gente que lleva una tonelada.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, en un espacio chiquitico.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y eso pesa una tonelada y le cobro...
[SPEAKER_00]: El tamaño nada, porque es pequeño.
[SPEAKER_05]: El tamaño, que ahorita tenemos un mínimo de 60 dólares.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y podemos registrarlo ya sea por volumen o por alto, largo y ancho.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tenemos una fórmula para...
[SPEAKER_05]: Trixx que es el largo, el alto por ancho entre 12, 14, 16 por la tarifa que tiene el cliente.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Y el cliente de ustedes puede ver directamente, ah bueno, puede verlo desde la página, puede hacer una calculadora virtual de cuánto le costaría el producto?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, eso lo hacemos nosotros, pero hemos querido hacer mucho eso para la paquetería para poderle cotizar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Aquí el mismo sistema...
[SPEAKER_03]: Pero aquí, perdón, aquí el problema es que muchas veces muchas tiendas te envían en diferentes cajas.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hola, hola, hola, hola, hola.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, ya unificar todos los pedidos es más complicado.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y estás enseñando el sistema.
[SPEAKER_00]: El sistema.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y aquí, por ejemplo, en administración tenemos las tarifas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí están las tarifas de los clientes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cada cliente tiene una tarifa diferente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Si te fijas, él paga esto, él paga esto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero la fórmula es la misma.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alto, largo, por ancho, entre 12, 14 y 6 multiplicado por esta tarifa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el sistema, al ponerle ya sea por volumen o por medidas,
[SPEAKER_05]: Te toma la tarifa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tú eliges al momento de estar registrando tu guía.
[SPEAKER_02]: No te imaginas lo que nos costó, bueno, le costó a Marilena el trabajo enseñarles a implementar esta plataforma.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí asignas la tarifa, aquí eliges tú la tarifa del cliente.
[SPEAKER_03]: Es que no sabía ni usar correo electrónico, mucho menos un Word, un Excel, nada.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y el acceso a esta plataforma es...
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviamente es un número grande de empleados, pero el que más tiene contacto con esta plataforma es la paquetería que está en...
[SPEAKER_05]: Él porque él es muy...
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo creo que es el que más...
[SPEAKER_05]: Todo de USA es el que sí la usa porque sus clientes están... Llego mi paquete ya... Sí, son personas, individuos que están constantemente...
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos sí tienen una oficina en Guadalajara y tienen personal y están dándole como un constante seguimiento a todo su...
[SPEAKER_05]: Trayecto por ejemplo ahorita me habló va a llegar camión entonces aquí aquí pues en teoría ya generaste la guía y aquí le asignaste la tarifa eliges la tarifa del cliente ahorita porque no complete toda la información pero y ya te sale una guía de esta manera envías listar guías aquí por ejemplo y eso es una guía que se generó de acuerdo a la información que se capturó y
[SPEAKER_05]: Este, aquí podemos ver el PDF de la guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: A él se le registraron todos los productos, aquí tiene su precio de tarifa y se le van a cobrar $7,000 dólares por esta mercancía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Les he dicho muchísimo, no pongan Rubén, o sea...
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, sabemos quién es Rubén porque es Rubén.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, no, aquí pues es Rubén.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, René no pone los apellidos porque dice que Ticho le va a robar los clientes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Es que ahí tenemos un cliente entre un cliente René y un cliente Paula Ticho que ellos creen que, bueno... Se ha pasado, porque a mí también me han pedido información en mi paquetería y yo doy, ya tengo un cliente y luego me hablan que porque me robé.
[SPEAKER_03]: Y yo no robo nada.
[SPEAKER_03]: O sea, los clientes van buscando pues... está complicado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces aquí están las guías y digo el sistema a lo mejor no es el más moderno pero nos has sacado la trazabilidad y entonces ya una vez que generas que es una persona que capturando aquí también tenemos a alguien que captura información de un cliente y se conecta a VPN para poder imprimir
[SPEAKER_05]: Desde una computadora en Berno.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces tiene el cliente, la persona que está... Con AnyDesk, perdón, se conecta AnyDesk.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, para imprimir a la empresa en Berno.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y imprime las etiquetas porque este programa tú puedes imprimir la etiqueta.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Perdón, ahí no es.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este, imprimes... Tengo que traer una guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, y ya una vez que tienes la información...
[SPEAKER_05]: Se crea un consolidado, le llamamos consolidado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, esta es creada.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay algo que viene dentro de toda una caja seca.
[SPEAKER_05]: De los paquetes de la sumatoria, de los paquetes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, es una guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, ya que está en bodega, todo lo que entra en almacén pues lo va registrando, ya sea con el tracking o lo va registrando y le vas generando una guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: La persona en bodega le crea un consolidado que si se nos ocurrió posponerle, no sé, y ya buscas un consolidado y aquí puedes sacar algunos reportes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ningún reporte ha cumplido con mis expectativas de todo lo que les pido porque
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo lo quiero muy específicamente y no le hago, a lo mejor, un seguimiento.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero, por ejemplo, aquí tengo estos reportes Trixx, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Y ya tengo un reporte de lo que viene dentro del camión.
[SPEAKER_00]: Siendo todo USA, el cliente que más organizado está.
[SPEAKER_05]: En cuanto que ahí sí revisa el programa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Por ejemplo,Paula Ticho siempre habla ¿en qué consolidado va?
[SPEAKER_05]: No entra, o sea, ella no va a entrar nunca a su sección de cliente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, tenemos ya aquí, entonces yo ya sé en el camión qué es lo que viene.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí yo ya puedo saber qué salió del almacén y en qué camión va y cuando llega al
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué le toca llegar a Guadalajara, que es el centro de distribución donde ya llegan todos los paquetes?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué es esta bodega?
[SPEAKER_05]: La tengo registrada aquí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ellos con un escáner van escaneando uno por uno para saber si ya llegó.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ya llegó, ya van avisándole a los clientes y ya llegan.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y este sistema quiere decir que los reportes no representan lo que tú quisieras ver, qué te gustaría recibir de esta plataforma, cuál es la información que vos querés entender más.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo siempre quise tener como un programa propio porque este lo pagamos y como que tener mi propia base de datos cotizamos pero siempre se tardaban como muchísimo en desarrollarlo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hector empezó como a desesperarse mucho y pues se tuvo que contratar un programa que en este programa he batallado mucho porque haz de cuenta como es una plataforma yo ya tenía establecido cierto parámetro y estábamos trabajando muy bien y de repente ya no aparecía lo que yo pedía
[SPEAKER_05]: Y resulta que otro cliente pidió otra cosa y modificaba lo que yo estaba trabajando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Otro cliente de la compañía en general.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, ¿qué pasó?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ya estábamos trabajando bien.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo trabajaba remotamente mucho con un venezolano como para irlo adecuando a nuestras necesidades.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita ya le perdí la...
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que ya me hiciste una de las cosas y ya no he estado como al pendiente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, por ejemplo, el reporte que más usamos este es Saiden 2.
[SPEAKER_05]: A ver si este es, no sé, China, quiero uno como muy completo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este nada más trae un contenedor de China.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cuando nada más es un contenedor, pues trae una línea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero déjame ver un contenedor que se ha llegado a Guadalajara con varios.
[SPEAKER_05]: Para que veas cómo viene surtido.
[SPEAKER_03]: Es que este proveedor de este servicio, o sea, muy pocas cosas se pueden personalizar porque ya está estandarizado para los clientes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro y si lo cambian pasa lo que le pasó a tu mamá, que si lo cambian se lo cambian a todos los clientes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero lo que mi mamá quería es algo que realmente 100% Sea un programa para ustedes, que ustedes lo manejen y que esté organizado a las medidas de ustedes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y este programa que tienen actualmente, ¿qué es lo que les gusta, qué es lo que no les gusta?
[SPEAKER_05]: Obviamente, pues esto lo podemos profundizar más adelante para ver... Sí, yo creo que eso será como lo último, yo creo, de la...
[SPEAKER_05]: Por ejemplo, a Guadalajara el Consolidado 2237.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ese iba a Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_05]: 2237 Este mira que aquí le entrega lo que yo he luchado mucho en Guadalajara es que me le entrega este el 100% al verde tambien le he bloqueado estos meses entonces ese es el reporte
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí como puedes ver ya ese es un camión completo que viene con los tracking como te comentaba su tracking de origen los que sí se generó guía y aquí aquí lo que yo quiero trabajar mucho es la cobranza saber
[SPEAKER_05]: Si el cliente paga, o sea, si todos pagaron.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Todo esto entonces llega a cartera y ustedes lo mantienen en una cartera de deuda que tiene el cliente con ustedes sin necesidad que él pague?
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que cada cliente paga diferente, por ejemplo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y cada cliente tiene una tarifa diferente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ha sido muy complicado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Algunos sí se pagan desde Los Ángeles y otros pagan al llegar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este, a Paola Ticho ya se le está cobrando por pie, a todo de USA por lo que le llegue de acuerdo a las medidas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dorthu Dorus Uncle es la paquetería local.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces este ya es el reporte de todo, que vienen medidas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nosotros nos basamos mucho en el volumen para cobrar.
[SPEAKER_05]: El volumen es el resultado que te comentaba del alto, largo por ancho de la medida de las cajas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero por ejemplo a todo de USA recibe no sé mil paquetes pero como recibe mucho paquete pequeño a él no se le cobra por paquetito sino que ya es el conglomerado se le cobra por tarima entonces el querer hacer una cobranza aquí en el sistema si todos esos se registraron con un volumen con un volumen pues no me representa lo que va a pagar en realidad entonces el querer hacer una cobranza ya de un consolidado son
[SPEAKER_05]: El que fue por medida, el que fue por volumen, el que fue por caja, el que fue por tarima, entonces es algo complicado, no imposible, pero actualmente es algo complicado el poder definir porque tienes que entrar a cada cliente como le cobré para ponerle un valor.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, si por ejemplo aquí dicen todo de USA, traigo cinco tarimas,
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues no le puedo cobrar por cliente individual, sino tengo que irme acá abajo, no sé si aquí trae la todo de USA.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tengo que ir acá, cuántos con solidaridad, cuánto de USA.
[SPEAKER_05]: Él acá si sale, le llamamos a eso, Love Unit le llamamos al...
[SPEAKER_05]: Esa es Unit, entonces le tengo que comprar por Unit pero le tengo que comprar por Unit pero de aquí a aquí es un precio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este todo esto venía en una tarima y este es un precio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y luego de acá este otro es otro Unit y de aquí para acá es otra tarima, es el contenido de todo lo que trae en otra tarima y es otro precio.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí yo tuviera que entrar a los Unit entonces tengo que irme a la lista de los dos Unit
[SPEAKER_05]: Aquí está también el sistema pareciera, bueno este lot unit costó 500 dólares y aquí ya ponerle 500 dólares.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este lot unit me costó... Ah, como si fuera un pallet de... Es todo el contenido de una unidad, eso es con un cliente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces esa parte también hay que unificar lo que... toda la ganancia que se tuvo en una caja completa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, entonces eso es esto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, para grandes rasgos, este...
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues estamos haciendo como muy detalle.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces acá, ese es el programa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y los warehouse son la mercancía que llega al sistema.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pickups que no las usamos, aquí pudiéramos, por ejemplo, cada salida que hace Rosy a un almacén.
[SPEAKER_02]: Con una tableta que este el gordito pase.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Sabes que estoy haciendo un picard?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ella, Rosy le puede generar un logjuni.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hicimos unas pruebas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Vete para acá, vete para allá y el lunes sale con una orden, el martes sale con otra orden.
[SPEAKER_05]: Esas son las pruebas que hicimos en el 22 y 23.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, nada más quedó como pruebas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, sí, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sabemos que sí funciona porque hicimos pruebas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero necesitamos la tableta especial para que el gordito esté.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Sabes qué Rosy le manda?
[SPEAKER_02]: Bueno, pues mañana tiene que ir a la mercancía de BUSA que cobramos 800 o 600 dólares, cruza Eduardo, se va, es un pick-up, ya se lo lleva a Los Ángeles, vete a la bodega y tiene que llegar ese e inmediatamente, inmediatamente en cuanto estén descargando, ¿sabes qué?
[SPEAKER_02]: Este urge o porque traemos otro problema también aquí que es algo
[SPEAKER_02]: Esto se va, pero hay mercancía que se va acumulando.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hace mucho que no la veía así tan vacía.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque no trabajaron el lunes, pero ahorita van a empezar a llegar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y también tenemos el problema de mercancía que se va quedando razonada acumulando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que en Almacén ya sé que son primeras entradas, primeras salidas, pero...
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, ahí puede causar un problema de... con el montacargas que lo muevas y se le cae... Se cae todo, sí, eso es la pierde de la estabilidad.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, no, eso es cabrón.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mira, ahí están a bus.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, ahí están a bus.
[SPEAKER_05]: No está el reto, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, yo creo que ya es mañana regresar.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, ahí tengo un tirano ahí que dijo...
[SPEAKER_00]: Ese sí los pone a...
[SPEAKER_05]: No, pero ve lo que mandó la señora Patti.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, ve lo que mandó la señora Patti.
[SPEAKER_02]: Los pone a correr uno tras otro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero sí, pero interno, pero lo que no se me hace correcto es a los clientes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ve lo que le pone la señora Pato.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, está bien, a lo mejor de manera interna, que no debería.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero ya, pero ya.
[SPEAKER_05]: Por él.
[SPEAKER_03]: Este... Y no se pueden borrar, pues.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y ahora que mencionas, perdón, te interrumpo, María.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Cuál es como la comunicación externa?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Cómo es el proceso de comunicación externa hacia los clientes de ustedes?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Normalmente cómo funciona?
[SPEAKER_00]: Porque si esa persona responde también a los clientes, tienen Facebook, ¿cuáles son como los caminos de comunicación?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nulos.
[SPEAKER_05]: No tienen... Es que él es una persona que estuvo en... él es un mexicano que está allá y... Bueno, sí tiene residencia.
[SPEAKER_05]: De hecho, por eso ahorita salió unos días porque acaba de recibir...
[SPEAKER_05]: No, su residencia.
[SPEAKER_05]: No le había llegado su tarjeta de residente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, ya.
[SPEAKER_00]: Un cliente quiere hablar con ustedes para hacer una pregunta y puede tener acceso a esta persona y les gustaría como canalizar eso o... Bueno, él está ahí y va a recibir y... Es más bien si alguien va y...
[SPEAKER_05]: No, él ha corrido.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hemos tenido a dos empleados ahí, tres empleados que ha corrido porque no...
[SPEAKER_00]: Si no, no sé.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Por qué no?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Por qué no me haces caso?
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, Hector ha sido muy tolerante.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces, él quiere aprovechar esta entrada del socio inversionista.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, te volví a uno al tema de este chino ya.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, sí, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahorita hay una pista de inversionista B5 que si inviertes un millón cincuenta mil dólares obtienes tu residencia.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y posterior tu ciudadanía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es la única visa en la que pudieras tener tu ciudadanía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Residencia sí, hay otras visas que puedes tener tu residencia, pero nunca aspirar a una ciudadanía.
[SPEAKER_00]: Esa te extiende la posibilidad de a X tiempo poder ser ciudadano.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces queremos aprovechar la entrada de Jan que ya le consiguió ahorita un abogado que fue cónsul en el que lo va a asesorar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el contador nos va a hacer, lo que te piden es que hagas un plan de negocios en el que él va a invertir ese millón de dólares en la empresa para, y queremos aprovechar ese momento para decir, Jan es el nuevo dueño de Trixx.
[SPEAKER_00]: Va a ser como la reforma de la compañía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ya esa persona, Beto, se tiene que adaptar a lo que diga el nuevo dueño.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces Héctor quiere de alguna manera aparentar estar
[SPEAKER_05]: No sabe escribir, no sabe ni usar el computador.
[SPEAKER_05]: Así me manda los reportes, a mano.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le tomo una foto en WhatsApp y te lo manda a mano.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí, así, literalmente.
[SPEAKER_03]: Él sí se ve que no tiene, perdón, estudios ni nada.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, educación mínima.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, él así me manda.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es real.
[SPEAKER_05]: Así.
[SPEAKER_05]: Las cargas y descargas, así.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, pero por lo menos la letra es legible.
[SPEAKER_05]: Las cargas y descargas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Las cargas y descargas las manda así, y yo se las tengo que regresar así.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, si tengo que coger toda esa información y pasarla a mano en Excel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, se las tengo que regresar así.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero me gustaría también, por ejemplo, esto me ha ayudado aquí en un chiste de recepción.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero ella escribe y yo no sé si él me está repitiendo un contenedor.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, a mí me gustaría que al momento de que vuelva...
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces ella tiene como a lo mejor muchos Excel donde tiene esta información, pero no hay como... Está suelta, la tiene en un Excel nuevo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ajá.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces a mí me gustaría que al momento de que capture las cargas, las cargas le llaman a lo que cargan así en esta caja seca y la descarga lo que sale de aquí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y nosotros le pagamos a los choferes por carga 500 dólares y por descargar 300.
[SPEAKER_05]: No hay...
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces el contenedor, un contenedor, te digo, se descarga y al momento de cargarlo yo quiero saber en cuál lo cargaron.
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque nada más tengo la descarga del contenedor y la carga.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero la carga, no sé si lo cargaron en cuál.
[SPEAKER_05]: Se supone que lo mete al sistema, entonces tenemos la información, te digo, como...
[SPEAKER_00]: En todos lados.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y no consolidada, por lo que entiendo, porque tienes muchas hojitas de Excel con información de un día, el otro día, el otro día, y no tienes como el histórico de venga, yo quiero ver la formatoria todos esos días.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Cuántos le he cargado a Carlos?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Cuánto se cargó el contenedor tal?
[SPEAKER_05]: Las cajas estas, la caja 50, pero es 82, que son las que van bien en cuántas vueltas dio en el mes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ya pues como para pasarte a otra pregunta,
[SPEAKER_00]: Porque veo que hay como me dijo Andre el sábado que hablamos hay como muchas cosas que se puede muchas oportunidades de mejora de procesamiento desde inclusive pensar en una plataforma nueva que se puede hacer digamos que está dentro pues de las posibilidades obviamente hay que empezar a ver temas de complejidades hasta soluciones muy básicas y muy pequeñas que puede ser como poder tener un consolidado o pues básicas digo en lo que entiendo en el momento
[SPEAKER_00]: Él me está mandando una foto de una cosa que él escribió a mano y me gustaría tener todo eso consolidado.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí, porque ahí por ejemplo también me manda además de esto la relación de los clientes que pagan ahí en bodega.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, esto y luego me manda una caja para Antonio 110 dólares.
[SPEAKER_05]: Una caja, pero no me pone el número de la guía que generó.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bueno, a lo mejor esa es la guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: A lo mejor esa es la guía.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces me pone así.
[SPEAKER_05]: También lo hice hacer esto ahorita, la autorización de salida.
[SPEAKER_05]: Le he dicho tres veces, nada más son las salidas y me está poniendo las entradas.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo necesitaba saber a qué hora salió el contenedor, a qué chofer se lo entregó, a qué compañía transportista se lo entregó.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el otro día le dije, aquí no tiene fecha.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, no me acuerdo qué fecha se lo di.
[SPEAKER_05]: No me acuerdo qué fecha o el día.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, no me acuerdo.
[SPEAKER_03]: Este cuadrito yo lo hice, pues, que yo, pues, no sé.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, pero pues es que lo parezco mucho más organizado.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exacto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces yo nada más lo tengo ahí y pues lo tengo ahí nada más porque le di lata porque no le estoy dando ninguna función.
[SPEAKER_05]: O sea, no lo estoy usando para nada porque la información no la estoy vaciando en ningún lugar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Si tuviera una tableta donde estudiar la información y el chofer quien le da la salida lo firme, le tome la foto.
[SPEAKER_05]: De hecho el programa tiene para hacer eso y tenía la tableta y puedes usar una tableta y puedes tomarle foto y si le toman en Guadalajara lo que sí hacen son evidencias de salida.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y también está la aplicación, este programa tiene aplicación.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tiene aplicación en el que yo le puedo poner una compañía y una guía y ya saber si la entregaron.
[SPEAKER_05]: En Guadalajara he trabajado mucho en el sentido de que cuando hagan una entrega tomen la fotografía y la identificación de quien se lo entregaron.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero pasa mucho lo que dices, entiendo, que toman la fotografía y si te llega la fotografía a ti, pero eso igualmente no se está haciendo un tráfico, pues...
[SPEAKER_05]: No, ajá, llega la fotografía, yo nomás lo tengo por si hay un reclamo Tú sabes, te tocaría meterte a revisar el día... Porque hubo muchos robos en Guadalajara, hubo muchos que no se sabía, que no le entregaron, que... ¿Y tienes un ejemplo de fotografía por ahí?
[SPEAKER_04]: A ver, déjame ver...
[SPEAKER_05]: A ver, si pongo aquí a lo mejor el nombre de Ignacio Medrano.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hay que buscar escribiendo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ahí está Ignacio Medrano, sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ahí está mi hermano.
[SPEAKER_03]: A ver este...
[SPEAKER_03]: Perdón, ¿ya se fue Eduardo?
[SPEAKER_03]: No sé, ¿para si pudiera ir mañana a comprar nachito o más cosas?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, sí, nos lo va a mandar el jueves.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Qué puedes mandar mañana?
[SPEAKER_05]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_05]: A ver este... Aquí está.
[SPEAKER_05]: Lo entregaron, la identificación y la firma, no le tomaron foto al producto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mira, aquí está la foto.
[SPEAKER_05]: A lo mejor el otro sí tenía foto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Le toman foto a la mercancía.
[SPEAKER_05]: De lo que se va a llevar y a la identificación.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero me ha costado, eso sí me costó horrores que me hicieran caso.
[SPEAKER_05]: Entonces digo, el programa sí, sí está, sí, sí cumple.
[SPEAKER_05]: Lo que batallo es en este reporte, pero pues a lo mejor porque el mismo sistema no sabe que yo cobro de una manera diferente.
[SPEAKER_05]: A René se le cobra por comisión.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Cuáles serían esas pequeñas victorias que de pronto no requieren una implementación tan compleja como un nuevo programa sino que puede ser algo más sencillo como por ejemplo la automatización de lo que tiene que hacer Andrea en el día a día?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, pero es que ese tipo de pequeñas victorias pueden ser como un comienzo de comenzar a entender también la logística y la información de la compañía porque vamos viendo desde los procesos más pequeños cómo se pueden automatizar y eso también te puede permitir a ti más tiempo para aplicarlo en otras tareas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, ¿cuáles creen ustedes dos que serían de pronto esas pequeñas victorias que se pueden implementar en un corto plazo que generarían un impacto
[SPEAKER_00]: La compañía en temas de tiempos, en temas de manejo de información, de presentación de información, que no requiera...
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Pero en qué te refieres que alguien tuviera que estar revisando?
[SPEAKER_03]: Ah, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: O sea, digo que aún así sí tuviéramos que estar checando.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, por supuesto.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, pues no se va a mandar así.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ajá, que no se mande así.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pues eso es dependiendo de la necesidad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Por eso les pregunto, digamos que una pequeña ganancia podría ser eso.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, no es que tú tengas que copiar y pegar, pegar documentos, pegar información, sino que simplemente a ti te llega un documento y tú lo revisas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces es mucho más fácil revisar un documento que copiar y pegar, copiar y pegar, copiar y pegar, copiar y pegar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y también puede que el ser humano se equivoca y a veces comete errores, entonces también reduce ese margen de error digamos que por parte humana.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y hay otra cosa en la que Graciela lleva nada más la información del chino en un programa Monday.
[SPEAKER_05]: No sé si has escuchado de él.
[SPEAKER_05]: Monday no.
[SPEAKER_05]: Monde, yo ahorita vamos con ella para que te enseñe.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero a mí esa información que ella vacía en ese formato, Monde, que lo lleva una persona de China, lo lleva una persona de México y lo lleva ella, como que cada quien complementa o agrega la información que yo he entrado cien veces a querer hacer uno para ti y nunca he podido.
[SPEAKER_03]: Es de automatizaciones también, pero es súper famoso en Estados Unidos.
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Esa información que ella maneja solamente para el chino en ese programa es la que a mí me gustaría manejar la misma información pero para Trixx en general?
[SPEAKER_05]: Es información que ella tiene que se vacíe para no volver a llenar y complementar con la información de los clientes que llegan por...
[SPEAKER_00]: Y más o menos así por encima.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, después de la automatización, más que todo, optimizar el proceso, ver cómo de pronto va a necesitar reportes más rápido, logística información también un poco más rápido.
[SPEAKER_00]: De Colombia, sí señor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Todos los contenedores se llaman así.
En el limbo, donde vienen, donde van, alertas, el borde, campañita, lo que se nos pasa, todo eso es muy importante.
Ah, pero llegan muchos correos, ¿verdad?
Luego llegan correos.
¿Cómo se llama?
Recabados.
Llegan los correos, más en viernes.
Amanecen unas con 500 correos que llegan muy a veces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y luego unos se van a España, otros no llegan.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué se pasa con el tema de los correos?
[SPEAKER_05]: Que ya hay muchos correos haciendo notificaciones de llegadas al puerto.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Cómo es el proceso?
[SPEAKER_01]: Son las notas de archivo cuando llegan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces lo que podemos hacer es si se pueda canalizar por todos los que me manda Ricardo se vayan directamente a la carpeta, todo lo que sea, no sé, nena, se vayan a la carpeta, hablando de las navieras, de las terminales, para saber
[SPEAKER_01]: Hablantes de Trixx Logistics en Trixx Logistics en Trixx Logistics en Trixx Logistics
¿Y sabes qué?
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Qué respuesta?
[SPEAKER_03]: Dice que no quiere.
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Cómo haces esa modi para que la vengan en el momento?
[SPEAKER_03]: Que no te... Ya llegó un domingo, o temana, ya llegó un viernes en la noche, cuando llegas a Andicronda, llegas poquito y dices, qué madre, 600 colores en el ciento.
Porque entonces te vas a los contenedores, a la propiedad, porque ahí es la que vamos a revisar, que es lo más importante, entonces ya lo vamos a revisar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces todo eso es lo que, las situaciones que nosotros queremos tener controlado, que no se nos salga de la mano porque eso es lo que genera y nos cuesta dinero hablando de demoras y almacenajes.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Y les llega algún otro tipo de notificación o es todo directamente por correos?
[SPEAKER_01]: Por correos, todo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Todo es por correos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Todo lo que se maneja de contenedores con terminales y Navieras es 100% correos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ellos no mandan Whatsapp ni te marcan por teléfono para decirte algo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Todo ello se hace por mensajes que los corporativos y las grandes compañías hacen por correos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Todo es correo.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Qué plataforma de correos, qué host de correos utilizan ustedes?
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿GoDaddy?
[SPEAKER_00]: GoDaddy, sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Podemos cambiar a otra?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí, no, pero eso es analizarlo, yo creo que... ¿Es de boda o es de los otros?
[SPEAKER_01]: No sé cuál estás usando.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, es el personaje que es el de Trixx.
[SPEAKER_01]: Es que en el management que es de boda no llegan correos de gmail y de hotmail, sólo llegan correos de... Sí, sí llegan, gracias.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, tú no puedes mandar a... Sólo puedes mandar como a... ¿Voy a decir pues?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ya se fue el amigo colombiano, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_02]: No señor, aquí todavía los acompaño.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, es que, pues, aproveché que Luis le diga lo de los, esas, los inquietudes que tenga de los correos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digo, que más que nada son las alertas de los correos que van a llegar y todo para que no nos ofrecen demoras y almacenajes.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Cómo podemos filtrar o cómo podemos canalizar que se vayan directamente a una carpeta?
[SPEAKER_01]: Para nomás abrir esa carpeta y no abrir los 600 en ese centro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ese es un... una inteligencia artificial que se puede hacer con una aplicación, con algo que se pueda... Sí, me llegan 25 correos en una noche.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, es poquito, hijo, nos vamos un viernes nosotros de aquí a las 6 de la tarde por las 5, bueno, yo a las 2.
[SPEAKER_01]: Llegas el lunes, tu pinche bandeja ya tiene 600 correos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ajá, eso, o sea, todo eso...
[SPEAKER_02]: Es muy importante para nosotros.
[SPEAKER_02]: Qué buen punto.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muy buen punto.
[SPEAKER_02]: El hacerlo manualmente, tener una persona es un costo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tendría que tener una persona especialmente a estar viendo correos y esa persona desafortunadamente no es un robot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Va a llegar un momento en que
[SPEAKER_02]: Te va a dar nomás click click click click que se va a dar y no va a estar leyendo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces necesitamos esa aplicación que creo yo que alguien traía de la inteligencia artificial.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y ella nos acomode todos los correos en orden de una alerta donde se te va a vencer este, este, este, estos son importantes y reacomoda.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, sería un criado o sería usando la plataforma.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahorita lo que escuché de Andy que Vodari es
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues no es pésimo, simplemente de Gmail o de Hotmail o de Yahoo no puedes mandarle a... Es que justamente Godaddy acaba de avisarnos que nos tenemos que emigrar a otra plataforma porque él ya perdió su capacidad, entonces ahorita se contrató a Microsoft, o sea Godaddy con Microsoft para que pueda abrir más correos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tiene dos, tenía dos opciones y ahorita se tiene que, tenemos que respaldar todos los correos
[SPEAKER_05]: Y en un lapso de dos horas ya va a tener más capacidadad en otra plataforma.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Sabes qué no me gusta a mí?
[SPEAKER_02]: Como estar teniendo parchecitos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tenemos a... Tenemos aquí a...
[SPEAKER_02]: Y luego tenemos a Samsanita aquí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tenemos un parchecito.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que son compañías que son funciones diferentes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, yo lo entiendo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y luego tenemos el dominio que, bueno, sí lo usamos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero esos detallitos son los que a veces nos provoca más personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Por ejemplo, ahorita.
[SPEAKER_02]: Para el monitoreo de los camiones, que dije al Miguel, necesitamos a una persona.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y ahora sí, sí lo necesitamos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Esa persona que esté monitoreando.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahorita me voy a acostar cosío hermano.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ese es un robotito, pero trae un... aquí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aquí trae un desfase de dos segundos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Un delay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero ese cabrón
[SPEAKER_02]: Es tan meticuloso, tan dedicado, tan esto, tan cuadradito.
Yo creo que tiene un poquito de asco.
TNH, un poquito.
Pero esos campos son excelentes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Son excelentes.
¿Por qué?
[SPEAKER_02]: Te vas a encargar de la flotilla que corre de Guadalajara a México.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y te vas a encargar...
[SPEAKER_02]: De mi reporte, que me reportes mantenimiento, llantas, operadores, rendimiento, todo, me pone con todo gusto, eso es lo mío.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y que me conteste así, chingón, chingoncísimo, pero ya me está costando.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque el cabrón de acá de Guadalajara, de Juárez, Guadalajara, sí lo hacen, sí están al pendiente, pero vemos a los choferes que les vale madre, hermano.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hector Leyla,Colombia,Colombia,Colombia
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso es lo que me refiero pues, tenemos todo pero lo tenemos todo muy disperso, con parchecitos y ahora tú, salió por ahí un cabrón que me cayó bien, ah dale, dale el trabajo ahí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya metí yo mi mano, ya echa a perder todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donde yo meto la mano, echo a perder algo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Todo echo a perder.
[SPEAKER_02]: El que está trabajando bien, el que está esto, llego que está haciendo nada, déjate por una pizza, déjate la regalar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya va a comer pizza, se acostumbró a la pizza.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si no le doy pizza la próxima semana, se va a encabonar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lo que menos quiero es meter ya mi mano.
[SPEAKER_02]: No quiero meter mi mano ya.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donde meto la mano he hecho perder todo.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Crees ya que vayan las cosas funcionando por su propio camino?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pues sí, a hacerme un pendejo a veces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Que las directrices de las operaciones o del funcionamiento de la empresa
[SPEAKER_01]: El tema es que las absorba la persona dedicada a esa función y a no más rendirle cuentas a este señor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Porque para él es muy fácil decir, el camión aquel, arreglalo, véndelo, chile su madre, no quiere ir, dale 200 dólares y vas a ver que va el cabrón.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces al día siguiente o la semana que viene, no va a querer moverse, va a decir no quiero ir porque vas a saber que le va a dar 200 dólares.
[SPEAKER_02]: Una buena niña, así bonita, así sin nada, no quiere ponerle chichis, ponerle extensiones.
[SPEAKER_02]: Echa esa parte de todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es la esencia de uno.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mal estoy yo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y yo reconozco.
[SPEAKER_00]: Acostumbrado a consentir a las personas.
[SPEAKER_05]: El del chofer que chocó le empezó a dar algo mensual a la semana.
[SPEAKER_05]: Y el carro en reparación, entonces no lo reparaba porque el señor tenía su pago a la semana.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué va a hacer?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Le va a sacar el carro?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Se va a ir a dar a la madre?
[SPEAKER_05]: ¿Tres meses se tardó en repararlo?
[SPEAKER_04]: Porque el escudo estaba pagando la semana.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hasta que un día sí dijo.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hasta que un día dijo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo quisiera aprovechar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero eso es muy importante, todo eso lo... Eso de los coches, yo me distraje.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso necesitamos...
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo creo que ese es el origen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Es que yo creo que eso es lo que le pregunté ahorita a María y a Andrea y aprovechando que están ustedes dos ya acá ya pues tenemos como ciertas pequeñas ganancias que podemos implementar o buscar la manera de implementar soluciones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Otra es la del correo, te quería preguntar a vos Héctor y pues aprovechando que también vamos a estar acá es que otras pequeñas cosas creen que nos requiere una implementación muy grande como por ejemplo lo que vos decís
[SPEAKER_00]: No sé, conglomerar todas las soluciones tecnológicas que ustedes tienen en una sola plataforma.
[SPEAKER_00]: Digamos que eso se puede llegar a hacer, pero eso requiere pues un trabajo digamos que mucho más largo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero sí hay pequeñas ganancias que podemos hacer como en los correos, como lo de pronto automatizar un proceso de poder sacar más fácil la carta porte.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Qué otra cosa ustedes creen que es algo pequeño pero que genera un impacto grande para el proceso interno de la compañía?
[SPEAKER_00]: Claramente, pues, filtrar los correos es una ganancia muy grande porque ahorra horas de trabajo y no solamente trabajo sino también económico recibió un impacto grande porque ya tiene las alertas primarias, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí, nosotros trabajamos muy desfasados.
[SPEAKER_02]: La hora, por ejemplo, de las bodegas en Los Ángeles se abre a una hora.
[SPEAKER_02]: El personal de carretera trabaja unas 24 horas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tenemos clientes chinos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Que nos está mandando Whatsapps a las 3, 4 de la mañana.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tenemos este, o sea, todo, todo, todo aquí se entra a las 10 de la mañana.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿A las 10?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿A las 9?
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿A las 9?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Llevamos cuatro meses entrando a las 10.
[SPEAKER_02]: No he visto que entran a las 9, pero bueno, a las 9.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, traemos un desfase en menor, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_04]: De todo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya para el viernes, digamos que para unos ya es salida, para otros apenas empieza el trabajo, el de Juárez se enoja porque es cuando tenemos más trabajo a partir de las 5 o 6 de la tarde, necesitamos esto, hacen berrinches, entonces sí necesitamos ponernos de acuerdo en el... Y ahora que traes esto Ricardo de la...
[SPEAKER_01]: De la automatización, de la proyección, ¿cómo esta palabra proyección podemos proyectar más la empresa?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Cómo la podemos hacer más conocida a nivel, digo ya nacional, parte de Estados Unidos o tal vez crecer internacionalmente?
[SPEAKER_01]: Que nos hagan pedidos de todas partes o que nos ubiquen más.
[SPEAKER_02]: En las redes sociales por Beto, eh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muy malos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Malos.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, a mí se me han ido clientes por Beto.
[SPEAKER_03]: Y eso ya no se puede borrar, pues.
[SPEAKER_03]: O sea, alguien entra y dice, a ver, ¿qué tal esta empresa?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, mala.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, por más, si ahorita contrato.
[SPEAKER_02]: A quien sea.
[SPEAKER_02]: A una, a la, a la empresa que te guste a nivel, por más dinero que le pague, van a ir a lo mejor a la bodega, pero con actitudes de cabrón.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya no sé qué hacer.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahora.
[SPEAKER_02]: Le puedo decir, ya no trate a la gente.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero, ¿sabes qué va a hacer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Me va a bloquear a quien lo trate.
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, con la cámara va a decir, a ver, Chaparito, tú te encargas de tratar a la gente.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uy, lo va a traer hasta que lo corra.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Me explico?
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, ese departamento me hago pendejo ahorita.
[SPEAKER_02]: No lo uso.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero lo necesitamos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque clientes tenemos muchos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, eso es algo...
[SPEAKER_02]: Eso es algo, la actitud, que sí, aparte que lo veo imposible de arreglar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Eso sí lo veo... Sí, porque para él está bien.
[SPEAKER_02]: El tema es que él no acepta... Es un trabajo muy difícil ahí.
[SPEAKER_02]: Muy difícil.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es un trabajo, de veras... Mira, pero han trabajado sábado, lunes, y ahorita, bien a gusto.
[SPEAKER_05]: Porque no están.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pero mira, mira, mira, nena, nena.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si no está quince días, al quinto día, sexto día, va a empezar el robo.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Me explico?
[SPEAKER_02]: O sea, yo prefiero tener a un tirano hijo de la chingada, que saben que si los fuerce, los va a agarrar chingazos, me van a reportar a mí y yo les voy a bloquear todo el trabajo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Es que tal vez en otro almacén, cuando los almacenes son más grandes, el personal, él estuviera acá en el área de carga y descarga,
[SPEAKER_05]: Y la parte de recepción o de atención al cliente esa la maneja otra persona pero él está...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo le dije un día al que encargado me vuelven a robar una pieza, una pluma quien sea Beto y usted se va.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pregúntame si nos volvieron a robar una.
[SPEAKER_02]: Andaba como un perro buscando agarrarme, corrió gente, me corrió mucha gente.
[SPEAKER_02]: Él me corrió mucha gente.
[SPEAKER_02]: Este equipo que tengo me costó mucho trabajo tenerlo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yo empecé a contratar gente con él, con la venia de él, y ya no tenemos problema de robo.
[SPEAKER_02]: No nos roban.
[SPEAKER_02]: No hay robo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tiene sus pros y sus contras.
[SPEAKER_02]: Él llega y los junta y les habla como un... ¿Qué te puedo decir?
[SPEAKER_02]: Un capatazo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero es una persona, Ricardo, que tiene un carácter muy especial.
[SPEAKER_01]: No nomás con los compañeros.
[SPEAKER_01]: Llega ese güey de UPS y también le dice, estacionate bien, no mandes cosas malas ahí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Con todo el mundo tiene una...
[SPEAKER_01]: Hector Leyla,Colombia
[SPEAKER_00]: Hablan en español.
[SPEAKER_05]: Como que se resulta contraproducente el decirle trata bien a esta persona o haz tanta actitud porque se vuelve contra.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y ahorita también a lo que, viendo la bodega, la bodega no está diseñada ahorita o el tamaño de la bodega no está diseñada para tener un área que el primer tope o la primera cara sea una cara bonita, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, tienes que llegar y ver si...
[SPEAKER_01]: Hablantes de la oficina.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hablantes de la oficina
[SPEAKER_01]: Se ha estado viendo, no sé cómo va el proyecto ahorita de conseguir una bodega en el otro lado más grande, o nos quedamos en esa o en la otra, pero no tenemos una recepción o un módulo de atención al cliente directo cuando llegan esas personas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces ya esa persona ya no te hubiera contado.
[SPEAKER_01]: Vengo y traigo una mercancía, ok, sí, ya está, ya la meto, ahora sí, voy a pasar por la mercancía y ya, o ya pase para allá y déjalo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero no, todo va a ser canalizado.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, no hay un filtro de atención primero, primario, al cliente, sino que es todo.
Pero creo que sí pudiéramos empezar con uno de los correos.
[SPEAKER_03]: Y no sé si a la Carla de las Cartas Porte o si es un...
[SPEAKER_00]: Ya les explico un poco cómo funcionamos nosotros normalmente lo que hacemos es esta primera reunión para conocer un poco más del funcionamiento de la compañía todo lo que me has explicado qué es lo que ustedes utilizan hoy en día cómo lo utilizan canales de información que tienen ya identificamos el tema de los correos lo de las cartas porte de pronto buscar una forma de agendar una cita pensando en soluciones para que de pronto haya una persona en el momento que un cliente vaya a ir
[SPEAKER_00]: Y que no tenga que recibir una persona que de pronto no está acostumbrada al trato comercial, por así decirlo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Digamos que esta es una primera etapa de análisis donde ya me llevo toda esta información, me llevo la conversación que tuvimos grabada y vemos una lista inicial como de propuestas o de posibles soluciones que nosotros podríamos implementar, se las presentamos a ustedes y ya vemos por qué canal queremos comenzar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces obviamente hay como esas primeras pequeñas ganancias que es lo que les precomentaba ahorita que yo creo que hay unas que se pueden hacer pues que pueden causar mucho impacto digamos que al general de la compañía porque obviamente si se pierde un correo eso ya son temas económicos, temas de multas que eso es muy importante entonces digamos que eso es una pequeña ganancia que se puede implementar en el corto plazo que es muy fuerte otra también pequeña ganancia es que tú te liberes de tiempo y eso pues es un
[SPEAKER_00]: Algo que tú me lo explicaste como persona, pues como individuo, pero de pronto puede aplicar para otras personas dentro de la compañía que te liberan mucho tiempo también para, no sé, hacer cualquier otro tipo de tarea que tengan ustedes aquí dentro de Trixx y que te sirva de pronto para lo que vos decías de venga busquemos más clientes, no sé, pues ya eso digamos que con el tiempo que se gane veamos pues como que se puede optimizar o como se puede desarrollar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces yo me llevo toda esta información
[SPEAKER_00]: Les presento una solución, la compartimos, después ustedes me dicen en qué momento.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Tú tienes visa?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo en ese momento, ¿para Estados Unidos dices o aquí en México?
[SPEAKER_00]: Para Estados Unidos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo tengo pasaporte español, entonces yo tengo visa no de trabajo, pero yo puedo cruzar sin ningún problema.
[SPEAKER_02]: Antes de que nos des una propuesta o una solución o algo, aquí fue nada más como el cafecito para el chiste.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sí señor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Siempre le he dicho a Marilena las decisiones que se toman de escritorio para mí nunca han sido las... tenemos que conocerla otra parte.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tiene uno que ir, ver el comportamiento, cuál es el flujo del trabajo, una platicadita con el personal, ver qué es lo que está pasando, o sea, no es lo mismo
[SPEAKER_02]: Que te digan, no, usted tiene que poner a una persona muy agradable así, pero así yo les pague ahí cinco mil dólares por semana y ponga a alguien bien agradable.
[SPEAKER_02]: El ambiente es duro, es duro.
[SPEAKER_02]: El ver maniobrar un camión, el ver que se echa de reversa, eso cuesta.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Cuánto cuesta diésel ese camión?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ver unos camiones impresionantes, las cajas.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Qué hay detrás de todo eso?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Dónde va ese paquete?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Dónde va esa mercancía?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Ese cliente con qué finalidad lo llevas?
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Para ayudar a tus familiares?
[SPEAKER_02]: No meternos en eso, pero sí por el precio que lleva.
[SPEAKER_02]: El que se dedica al negocio, el que manda por nosotros por necesidad, el que le gusta nuestro servicio.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ese tema lo he olvidado porque ya no sé qué esté pasando con los clientes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tenemos una cartera de clientes grandes, muchos se fueron por la actitud, muchos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Y quien quiera retomar, a ver, oiga, véngase, mire, le damos un precio especial.
[SPEAKER_02]: Como que no quiero que nos atiendan ese pinche viejo gordo, feo, déspota.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahí se me viene junta.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ahí, aunque me dé la solución, no es la solución.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pongo una barbie que nos atiendan ahí, no va a faltar la barbie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pongo a un señor que sea carismático, que hable de la Iglesia, de la Biblia, tampoco.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque se va a estar pudiendo predicar la palabra ahí y me va a echar a perder a toda la gente.
[SPEAKER_02]: Entonces, sí es un tema delicadón.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si quiero retomar al cliente que me deja más dinero, ese que le cobramos 300 dólares, 400 dólares y cada semana, cada 15 días va, pero se han ido por la actitud del personal que tengo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Otro tema es cuando llegan al destino en Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ese es otro tema.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es la parte dos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es parte dos y parte tres la de México con los llanes, yunes y ayer que me costó sesenta mil pesos una pendejada, una estupidez.
[SPEAKER_02]: Es lo mismo a lo que todos retomamos.
[SPEAKER_02]: Vamos haciendo confianza, confianza, confianza.
[SPEAKER_02]: Más la comunicación y ya hacen lo que ellos quieran.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ya él tomó la decisión.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Y a qué horas tomaste la decisión tú de mandar ese camión así?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, pues que se lo hizo fácil.
[SPEAKER_02]: ¿Y con quién?
[SPEAKER_02]: Y mira.
[SPEAKER_02]: Son seguimientos que también yo digo, bueno, seré el dueño, pero no puedo estar en todo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo creo que una cosa muy importante que precisamente tú lo estabas buscando es uno tiene que automatizar esos procesos, no para estar en el día a día de la operación.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sino para entender qué es lo que está pasando.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ustedes ya no están pues que están en una posición digamos que toma decisiones para ser operarios ni para estar resolviendo problemas que es que esa persona le respondió mal al cliente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ustedes tienen que tomar decisiones en información que les llega de todo el flujo de la cadena.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y esa información tiene que estar clara, tiene que estar al día y tiene que estar casi que en temas de logística inmediata.
[SPEAKER_00]: ¿Dónde está el camión?
[SPEAKER_00]: Puedes responderle al cliente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo creo que como vos decís, si es de cuestión de ir a campo, ir a conocer las personas, no solamente a Estados Unidos sino también en Guadalajara, en Monterrey en ese momento me dices la ciudad cercana, no me acuerdo el nombre.
[SPEAKER_05]: En Monterrey pues vas a empezar, probablemente vas a empezar más a trabajar ahí, ¿verdad?
[SPEAKER_00]: Bueno, va a empezar el lunes a ver si va a abrir el mercado.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo creo que es de tomarlo poco a poco, de empezar a ver casi que en el corto plazo cuáles son las pequeñas pasos que podemos dar para pisar fuerte y empezar a solucionar cosas que nos alivian en tiempo a todos y a partir de ahí ya con más conocimiento de la compañía ver qué otras implementaciones y desarrollos se pueden tomar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Porque es bien bonito platicar y tomar cafecito.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si a la hora de la verdad, a la hora de usted, como se dice en Colombia, hay que ver cómo se pueden solucionar las cosas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, bueno, yo creo que, excepto que me quieran comentar algo más, yo ya tengo pues como una visión un poco general de la compañía que toca puntualizar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nada más quiero que veas el programa Monday donde se está como vaciando toda la información.
[SPEAKER_03]: ¿Podemos agendar una visita?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, cuando quieran.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo con esto ya puedo por lo menos entregar pues un primer reporte del corto plazo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí me gustaría, la verdad, sí me gustaría para conocer más, para...
[SPEAKER_05]: Pues el jueves a Los Ángeles.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bueno, hay que cerrar eso también.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, yo podría.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lo único es que yo tengo que cruzar.
[SPEAKER_00]: En moto pero la puedo dar al otro lado.
[SPEAKER_00]: O caminando, pero caminando entre semana es un poco más complicado.
[SPEAKER_03]: O te animarías con Passeme y con el carro a los dos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah bueno, sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: También.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eso tiene sentido.
[SPEAKER_03]: No importa, este, nada más que estoy viendo...
[SPEAKER_05]: Si, vemos, vemos ya lo del cruce, pues ya.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, yo lo soluciono, no te preocupes.
[SPEAKER_00]: En últimas cruces motos la debo ahí y alquilo un carro y nos vamos para... pues eso sí es sencillo.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, pero si tenemos.
[SPEAKER_05]: Déjame ver si va Héctor.
[SPEAKER_05]: Veo si va a ir Héctor.
[SPEAKER_03]: Pues veré a Eduardo dijiste, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, pero Eduardo... no, pues a Eduardo nomás lo iban a mandar a llevar dinero.
[SPEAKER_05]: Este, veo si va Héctor y nos vamos todos a hacer una...
[SPEAKER_05]: Es más espacioso.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tiene un departamento en Los Angeles y a veces se queda.
¿No tienes cargador?
[SPEAKER_00]: En mi lugar hay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si quieres sí, vamos a ver el monte.
[SPEAKER_00]: Igual yo tengo más tiempo, no es que quiera.